hi I'm Tim Burton producer of Disney's  new Alice Through the Looking Glass as a  filmmaker you want the audience to be  immersed in the world they're seeing on  screen and this film truly comes to life  when you experience in IMAX so please  enjoy this exclusive special look of  Alice Through the Looking Glass friends  need you take case of female hysteria  untreatable some say I beg to differ  there's nothing wrong with me  you've been gone too long  when is she coming soon I've always  wondered have I come too bad  we'll split up together  my sister it's not someone you want as  your enemy what happened to you  would you always be so headstrong  you